[Music]
biscuits are great fellows got that ass
for days and you can too girl
with super booty enhancing Thanos but
geez that's best Thanksgiving gravy
piggies rolling up to the club with a
muscle-bound book you can see all the
way from ASCO Santos but jeans get u
infinity food and indubitably
take it for me and Ricky dad's got
customers tejanos but cheese gave me the
confidence I need to pursue my
engineering degree all aboard
thanks to Thanos but jeans I'm a
two-time Powerball winner and I got a
retweet from Shabba Ranks I'm Flynn
figured like a digital redo but with my
fountains but jeans I can do anything
even walk through walls
I love my new confident
I'm just glad they also make Dennis but
genes for men cinnamon toast crunch
that's a seven point dam on the booty
meters good thing we sell booty insurers
to to schedule your free estimate we've
a note for Marcus at that one bodega
where they sell bootleg karate movies
and baby turtles so what great job but
stars from iPhone to IMAX just like that
with vanos but jeans only from air
strikes available in France tourism
[Applause]
you